what's up elimination I have a very
special announcement and want to make a
really quick video to talk about it I am
launching my first event here in Toronto
teaching people how to make money from
their ideas basically teaching people
how to do the thing that I do but be in
your industry and it's a three-day event
May 23rd to May 25th the details we're
gonna put in the description it's on my
website I've been wanting to do this for
a little bit
mostly because you know I want to get my
hooks into people I love people to
answer questions in a Google hangout
YouTube hangout it's fun but I want the
context and since I've been getting into
Instagram live and you guys are joining
in on my videos and we get the
one-on-one time for five minutes ten
minutes I want to do more of that but I
want it I want it in an intense I
realize that when I see you guys in an
Instagram or an on YouTube live hangout
we chat for a little bit and it has a
bit of an impact but like I want to get
my hooks into you I want to I want you
to really feel the magic I want you
really oh man Nina Nina I can't look at
this look at the legs I can't fit Nina
holy cow hold on look at my settings
right here look at this as a squash
Devin
set number one they were your hope
what's happening what's happening is
happiness happiness happening I want to
get my hooks into you I want to take 15
people and really make a big impact I
really want to to touch lives it's super
important to me and what I'm doing is I
want I'm getting thought-leaders I'm
getting thought-leaders people who want
to have an impact who if it's YouTube or
Twitter or Instagram social media and
then how to turn that into a business
and how to make money from it and so day
one is going to be training it's gonna
be here's my entire playbook here's the
behind the scenes of how I post when I
post why I pose the type of content
lessons I've learned YouTube Twitter
Instagram across the board and answering
your questions on how you can do it too
we're also gonna be looking at creating
a Content schedule for you understanding
the types of content that will
which platforms and again what's working
for me and stealing my playbook and I'm
answering all your questions to help you
win then in the afternoon we're gonna
have lunch lunch with my team me my team
answering questions my team one-on-one
and then in the afternoon we're going
over business models I'm gonna talk
about how do you make money from brand
deals how do you make money from
advertising how to make money from book
deals and speaking gigs and consulting
and courses like how do you monetize the
ideas that you have and turn it into a
real business and close in a session
then with how to be comfortable in front
of the camera tips things that I learned
training that I spent 10,000 u.s.
dollars on my training to get better if
you guys look back on my old videos and
you see how awkward and nervous and
uncomfortable I was and I am NOT a
type-a personality I was super
uncomfortable in front of the camera and
I was able to turn that into what it is
now I don't want you to have to wait as
long as I did I want you be able to
learn from the $10,000 that I spent and
all the lessons learned too and then
again I want to be the answer the
question so the training is going to be
about half of each of the session and
then Q&A like I want to help you come
with your problems what you're facing
and and let's dive in that's the whole
idea of making the small 15 people max
and that's what we're going to go
through then we're gonna have dinner
together
have a blast answer questions again so
day 1 is all about training day 2 is now
we're gonna put the train into action
because what I don't want you to do is
just come and get some more training and
get some ideas and have a notebook full
of plans and then don't do anything how
many videos of mine have you watched
where you got some ideas and you took a
little bit of action and then life got
back in the way we're gonna do day 2 is
all about doing we're doing we're doing
we're doing we're pushing you we're
moving you stuff is gonna happen and
that's what I'm most excited by it we're
gonna work on how to tell your
foundation story we're gonna come up
with why you are doing what you're doing
then we're gonna do it on film you were
gonna tell it on film with me guiding
you with my camera man behind the camera
me got in you telling you do it again
fix this try this guiding you coaching
you one-on-one
while we film and then my editing team
is actually going to edit the video so
you have a final product that you can
put up on your YouTube channel on your
website that showcases why
you do what you do it's important
because the foundation story is the most
important video if you had one video to
make the foundation stories it and I
want you to get it down I want you to
have an amazing video and more
importantly I want you to get the skills
I want to see how you deliver your
message and I'm going to be there to
help you make it better I'm so pumped
yes anyway we're also going to work on
on day two making shorter form content
so making content for snapchat Instagram
Twitter short videos ten-second clips up
to a minute clip so we're gonna walk you
through it not just the ideas but do it
practice guys if you're coming you need
to have your account set up because we
are going to be making content on day
two and telling you do it again fix's
try it this way because I want you
leaving with the actual experience not
just more theory a theory is great I
love it but the whole point of this and
keeping it small is that you me and my
team are gonna help you crush 2018 and
then the last part on day two is we're
also going to be looking at your SEO
social media content and creating a
Content calendar a schedule a plan
understanding what your message is and
then having that pour out and what does
it look like in a design element in
picture format all of it to make it make
it amazing because I want you to have a
huge impact in 2018 that's the initial
goal I want you guys to win I want to
help I want to get my hooks into you
you can tell I'm excited and passionate
about it this came together super
quickly I sent out an email around it we
really got 40% sold out already by the
time this video goes up I mean it's
gonna sell out I'm not trying to be
sales II I want you guys whoever is it
whoever is interested in being a thought
leader this is gonna be the best
training possible for you if you don't
want to be a thought leader if you just
want to be an entrepreneur you just want
to do your craft this is not for you if
you want to be a thought leader this is
the best place to be d3 is an optional
day and this is where in the morning
it's going to be mastermind there's no
set agenda it's going to be me and
whoever has signed up for the bonus day
it's extremely limited availability for
that one and we're going to be talking
about whatever you want to talk about
your business your growth your
strategies and I'm going to give you my
feedback direct so come with
questions like it's gonna be great to
come and learn from the other people in
their questions and their challenges and
you'll learn something from it but
what's the biggest thing that's holding
you back right now what's the single
biggest problem or question you have and
then I want to help walk you through it
how I would handle it I want to give you
answers I want to understand your issues
and get you to a solution before you
leave the event it's super important to
me that you're getting value and you
come out a changed human being with not
just strategy but you have already taken
action before you have left and so the
morning is going to be that and then
we're gonna have lunch together the
afternoon is gonna be interviews so if
you if you want me to be on your podcast
your YouTube channel your Instagram live
your Facebook live whatever show you
have going on if you want me to be a
guest on it that's what I'm gonna be
lining up interviews with you guys so
it's limited availability because I
don't have that much spots open to be
able to do those interviews and so day
three is optional so far everybody who
signed up has gone with the day three
option two which is unexpected
I feel like I should have charged a
little more for the day three option but
anyway we're here and we're not
increasing the prices so a couple Q&A
some questions that kept coming in about
the event one are you gonna do it online
no this is not available online it will
never be available online the reason is
because it's not just about the training
it's about the experience it's me
working with you one-on-one and guiding
you and helping you and you work with
members of my team one-on-one guiding
you and helping you and that can't be
recreated online it's not just to follow
these eight steps and you win there's
some understanding of the strategy but
the biggest juice the biggest benefit is
going to be from the one-on-one
interaction and working together and so
I can't replicate that online and so I
want it to be something local and for 15
people max only some people asked am I
gonna take this overseas and I'm gonna
run this event again I don't know if
I'll ever do the event again this is a
test this is a fun project for me I'm
putting in way more time on this and a
lot of the other things that I probably
should be spending time live I may do it
again I don't know this might be the
only time I run it I might do another
one but I don't think it's something I'm
gonna take on the road I don't want to
be the guy who's traveling every city
putting on workshops I've rejected that
notion already as a speaker I could be
speaking every weekend at some other
event but family time is really
important to me and so I'm really
careful when I'm leaving the city about
where I'm going for how long I'm going
and the cause really really has to
matter so this is not something that I
plan on taking on the road if I'd ever
do run it again it will likely be in
Toronto so just for those of you
International I know somebody signup is
already from is already coming from
Germany you've got people coming from
America wherever you are I understand
the situations I know the cost of the
flight is more expensive but that's
that's really just where it's at I don't
plan on doing it online I don't plan on
doing it international for people to ask
what stage of business do I need to be
in it doesn't really matter the stage of
business what matters is that you want
to be a thought leader so you could you
could have a successful business and
then want to transition to be a thought
leader in an expert and get incredible
on YouTube on Facebook and getting book
deals and signed up for speaking gigs
and all that kind of stuff or you could
be a startup and that could be your plan
as well the most important thing is that
you want to be a thought leader if you
want to be behind the scenes not be the
face of the company not have your own
recognition but it's always company
first and you know product first that
kind of stuff amazing you can build a
huge business that way congratulations
but this course is not for you like
don't spend your money on it it will not
be a good ROI for you don't come it's
not who I want I want the people who
want to be at the front who want to lead
from the front who want to have a
personality who want to get those book
deals and speaking gigs and brand deals
and be the face of their business people
who have a mission people who are on a
mission they want to make a positive
impact in the world and they are going
to be the face of that mission that's
who I want if that's you this is the
best training course ever I am a hundred
percent confident if you at all like
what I do I'm basically to teach you how
to be the me in your industry and so I'm
super pumped by I think you can feel the
energy if you guys are interested you
can check out the link again in the
description if you have questions let me
know I'll try to answer them we're 40%
sold out already I don't know how long
it's gonna last before we sell out we
don't have instant
packages somebody asked me that it's
really first-come first-serve whoever
signs up you get in I'm really looking
forward to meeting you this is a very
deep personal emotional thing for me
everybody who comes I'm emotionally
invested in I badly badly badly want you
to win I'm gonna give you everything I
have for those three days I'm gonna care
for you like you are my family and I
want you to win so badly and so
hopefully they'll see you there if not
continue to enjoy the rest of the videos
on this channel thank you guys so much
for the love I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that that people with
passion not one drop of my self-worth
depends on your acceptance of me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten rows of success I have
a very special secret video for you
these are the individual clips that I
have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link in description for
details